you took over for this is exciting yeah
you you took over for Bradley Cooper in
the wet hot American summer that's right
series 10 years later that American
summer series taking us later and did
you know that you would be taking over
for Bradley Cooper mmm not really I it
was weird that I was like that would be
at all if they called me up and said we
need you to replace Bradley Cooper I I
would my response which i think is more
appropriate for me as you have the wrong
number
yes that's my response as well like I I
don't it's not doesn't really add up but
that's exactly what they want to be but
I agreed to do like I didn't even know
what it was my friend David Wain who is
wet hot American summer is he and
Michael Showalter 'he's thing and so he
just texted and asked if I wanted to do
it and I just said yeah sure of course
like I love wet hot American summer but
then he said okay let me call you I'll
tell you about the role and I was like
nah it's okay it's fine I'll just be
just went went and tell me when I have
to be there and it wasn't until a couple
of days before that I found out it's to
replace to play the same role as Bradley
Cooper's same role this is your role you
are Bradley Cooper yeah we just say they
just say he's like don't worry about
we're just gonna say you got a nose job
I could play him if he was it was 10
years later and he was transitioning
into a woman tower woman who had been in
an accident that's those are the
conditions in which I could play badly
Cooper so but you know what you get to
have scenes with Alyssa Milano yeah
listen I've met her and interviewed her
many times she is a just beautiful a
delight
yeah and it's Alyssa Milano now you're
getting creepy yeah it's Alyssa Milano
yeah
like you're looking at her through a
window
[Laughter]
we like you know we had scenes together
is great we have a fight scene and at
the end of the fight scene she's like on
top of me and we were just waiting for
the cam you know in between takes where
you lay around and you're just kind of
chatting with the other actors not even
thinking about it and it dawned on me
that Alyssa Milano is sitting on I'm
laying down and she's straddling me
we're just making chitchat not even
thinking about what's going on and then
it occurred to me that this is Alyssa
Milano and so I had to tell her like
eleven-year-old me would be losing my
mind right now it seemed like she gets
that all the time yeah that's a creepy
thing to say early 40s if I was 11 right
now I'd be losing it it's disgusting I'd
be losing all of it yeah you keep
sitting astride me don't worry about it
yeah just forget what I did you think
yeah Alyssa Milano has to hear that all
the times disgusting so but look you're
a bad guy yeah he lies that's amazing
thing about actors I mean I'm not an
actor you're an actor you have to learn
how to do that and be professional you
have to have sex scenes where you're you
know there's just a little piece of
cloth separating you know what's you
from someone else you do that kind of
stuff I only do that in my dreams man
sorry what do you what do you mean by
what's use a piece of cloth separating
what's you from the other person I was
trying to be delicate uh-huh you mean
like penises and vaginas this interview
is over
you